the season two was like five episodes
they just pulled the plug and so
good the people who loved it me probably
only me they were like just one girl in
philadelphia is watching this let's
cancel the show
hi i'm brian and i am here with tom and
nina and we are going to talk about
forgotten tv series that we think
should get a reboot tom
what tv series that is forgotten do you
think should get a reboot
if i had to pick one and i do because
you asked me to that's the assignment
keep in mind i'm going to
i'm a nerd right yeah i'm aware i'm not
adjusting well
to life in the outside i would love to
see more fire escape
specifically i would love to see more
fire escape with the kind of budget that
they
used to give to tv shows back when there
weren't as many tv shots
you remember when you would turn on deep
space nine it would just be
i'm sorry this is instantly turning into
an andy rooney like 16-minute
you're right back in the day
we used to be able to watch deep space
nine and see
yeah no really stories of aliens walking
around in a dangle
it was like the mall of america but it
was full of four head ridges yeah
uh no i would i would really
i loved farscape if you've never seen it
it was uh
jim henson's weird kid making his own
star trek that was just full of these
off-brand
kind of other sci-fi characters there
was a dude named rigel who
looked like fat yoda there was a
pilot who who was i always imagined him
as really small
but whenever you see him up close he's
huge yeah
he's this enormous and like i think and
they actually built the pup
it was all these pup they were all
puppets and weird prosthetics and
it's almost exactly like every other
good sci-fi show it took about a season
and a half for them to
stop caring enough to turn into
something neat
uh like once they once they got real
weird with it it was
so basically so briefly what's the
premise of farscape for those who may
not have seen it
so glad that you asked i mean like and
again i'm not i'm not big into geek
stuff i think i've mentioned that before
but basically what happens is i
ask a pilot is the international
aeronautics and space
association pilot john creighton is
launched into space on what's called the
farscape project
and accidentally slingshots himself
through a wormhole into another
uh area of the universe and finds
himself
on board a recently escaped uh prison
ship a living ship named
moya who's a uh it's called the
leviathan
it's this giant living uh prison ship
that's been taken over by
i want to say four of the of the
prisoners on the ship
something like that yeah three or four
from there
uh hi jake's in two right so basically
voyager but one guy
yeah yeah voyager smaller cast smaller
budget
uh everybody's covered in paint and goo
yeah i love it yeah so you want to see
sparskip come back
so would you say that you want this to
be a reboot would you want this to be a
sequel
what's your what's your dream version of
the new
2021 farscape i would love to see a
sequel personally and again not into
geek stuff but
when the peacekeeper wars left off the
mini series that they produced for i
want to say the hallmark channel
but back in the mid-2000s creighton's
son
had just had just been born oh and and
he was presenting him to the universe
in lion king fashion this was 17 18
years ago now and
we've got an adult child who goes out on
his own adventures and then we get to
bring back
the same actors because mostly they've
been doing either voice work or nothing
for the last
couple decades and i feel like we can
get them back pretty easily i love that
show
very much it's bonkers and delightful
and
if you can watch through it long enough
to get to an episode called crackers
don't matter
just it's good it's a good time
it's weird but i would love to see more
of it nina what is your pick for a
tv show that's been forgotten that you
want to see brought back
all right i gotta i got a weird one um
and
i'm gonna sound like i'm making fun of
the show because the premise is just
insane but i actually
loved this show and i watched every
episode when it was on and part of the
reason i'm going to preface this
part of the reason i want to bring it
back is really selfish is that it ended
on like five cliffhangers
because it was very abruptly cancelled
and i still kind of want to know what
happened
um so it's the year 2003
and uh if you were a fan of watching
things on fox
like 24 you might have seen commercials
for a show called true calling and true
is spelled t-r-u
and i'm gonna send you the poster right
now because it's one of those classic
just like
you know really like overexposed
mid-2000s tv posters with like a girl
staring yeah uh so you've got you know
a tiny jason priestley in the corner
you've got a huge elijah
eliza douche queue in the front so the
premise was that eliza dushku is a girl
named uh
true that's her name davies oh
was it short for trudy at least they
never confirmed that so her name was
just
true that's fine that sucks so she is
just wait it gets better she is a med
student and she starts working at the
morgue
and she pulls open a drawer one day and
a
corpse looks at her and says help me and
all of a sudden true is transported
back to the day that the woman was
murdered and has to prevent the murder
from happening
oh dear yeah so there's time travel
involved
yes but it's super specific i don't
really understand like
like she can't she never gets to decide
when she's time traveling it's just if
so it's pushing daisies it's pushing
daisy's meets
early edition meets quantum leap it's
pushing daisies if ned had no autonomy
about what he was doing
so true is just constantly set back in
time
exactly does she have to use like a
telephone to communicate with them
she like she gets sent i believe that
she gets it's really hard to watch the
show so i like tried to track down
episodes like they don't exist
anymore like it's it's hard to find it
but it was funny
no no it's a delight no it's very hard
to like find
yeah so you guys you guys are not gonna
laugh when you hear everyone else who
was on this show because there are some
famous people on the show um anyway so
like
she works in this lab uh the only i
think the only person who knows about
her uh power her true calling
her her true calling is her boss davis
yeah you get it now right and it turns
out
it turns out that her late mother uh who
i don't think that you ever see
also had the same power which kind of
folds into the story but the real
like the other reason i want this to be
brought back
is i don't think either of you are going
to guess well so a lot of people on the
show lizzie kaplan was in season two
aj cook from criminal lines played a
pretty large role as
lindsay true's best friend matt bomer
played her boyfriend
jason priestley shows up as a guy who
has the exact same power as true except
his name is not true
or any permutation of that word his name
is untrue but her abundance
sucks davis who also works in the morgue
is played by none other than a
little-known actor you might have heard
of named zach galifianakis
that's right and i want them to bring
this show back for no other reason than
to make zach galifianakis do this show
again
i mean because he would make it so much
weirder
you're not wrong you're talking to dead
could we call it between two urns
yes yes we can that's the only because i
don't want to nina because this whole
thing
sucks so bad nothing is going to fix
okay
let me tell you but her name is true it
was abruptly cancelled in 2005
on it was like it was like season two
was like five episodes they just pulled
the plug and so
good the people who loved it me probably
only me
they were like just one girl in
philadelphia is watching this let's
cancel the show
um there's one viewer she lives in
philadelphia
not good enough so yeah i mean
i just i remember being like you know as
a teenager being like i need to know
what happens but it's also just
it's such a delightfully stupid promise
zach galfinakis no one was like oh the
chubby lab tech is gonna be the biggest
star from the show and yet
and yet have you seen the show i zombie
yes it's a very similar premise done
much better it's a similar premise done
much better
i guess then that means that you won't
accept my
i was going to say it has been rebooted
as a better show called i zombie
but you're not into that you're like no
you want zac alvarez
and also is it she's a zombie which is
why she
right well it's a much better premise
like it's like she has to eat the brain
so she eats the brains of the people and
she she is a doctor she becomes a zombie
okay so she has to work in the morgue
and she eats the brains and her name is
i because she's a zombie and she needs
to eat her name
but when she does that she finds out
that there's unsolved murders and she
goes and solves the murders and it's the
exact same premise
as true calling without the time travel
and
for a pretty good reason well the other
issue with uh
with true calling like is she goes back
and she stops these people from being
she doesn't solve the murder she
prevents murders
so then she's directly contributing to
overpopulation
wow the problem plaguing our world dark
from every angle
she's changing she's changing history
she's literally altering
history so what if we had a true calling
spin-off where it was the ramifications
of every murder she prevented
oh my god what if it's a sequel series
and someone's
someone's going back in time to stop her
from stopping them
to set the timeline right i love it
there you go
tom's furious um so
i have never hated anything as much as i
hate what you just described for the
last five minutes
you're welcome oh if
you're so welcome that's my pick it's
true calling it was on fox
so my pick is also a cast off from fox
but from even
further back in history oh it's
it's a little show starring john rise
davies
and jerry o'connell yes no man
no sliders in another universe i do
sliders so the premise of sliders is
that
jesus physical pain quinn mallory
you wanted muppet star trek i guess yeah
my pitch was like let's put sock puppets
on michael dorn
and have a great day no this is i
deserve what's happening
sliders i think tom pick's the only show
anyone actually liked
i like spiders for a while i'm very
alone people really like far skinny
and so and so the premise of sliders is
that this guy invents
a machine that allows him to slide
from one universe to another so he and
three other people
a flawless premise his professor a girl
he's interested in and a random dude
who's driving him
gets sucked into a portal and the
machine breaks
so that he can't get home and they have
to keep sliding from university universe
to hopefully get back to their universe
hoping with each slide that it'll be the
slide
that finally takes them home dr samuel
beckett
absolutely there's a quantum leap
element to it
but the reason look the show was not
the best show but it's a great premise
so it's different from true calling and
that it was not the best show anyone's
ever seen
got it it was better than true calling
possible with this job and burned my
it was better than true calling that's
not possible
john jonathan rise davies is that's his
name right i'm getting yeah
yeah i'm very tired john rice davies the
legend from the lord of the rings
trilogy from
indiana jones and the raiders of the
lost ark amazing
so many movies he's a great character
actor and he's in this series as
professor arturo
and he's just chewing the scenery and
he's being a stuffy angry
professor guy who's talking to young mr
mallory and trying to get him to do
science better
and it's just this great premise because
from from one world to the next it's
basically
your built-in twilight zone machine
every universe there's something weird
there's some
weird thing that's awful it sounds like
a sloppier doctor who
it's not dissimilar from doctor who yeah
it is a sloppier doctor it's a little
bit more grounded than doctor who but i
think for me
if you went in with a good with a good
budget if you went in with a
with knowing what your arc is and maybe
a 10 episode
season and you say this is how we get
from
the first episode to the final episode
this is the story instead of saying like
gosh i hope we get picked up for the
next season
right because this was also made in an
era where like networks were producing
24 episodes a season right which
is just not tenable for anything it's
crazy that people used to do that
tighten it up yeah be specific with what
you're doing from world to world to
world
get a great cast get a good budget
you've got a really good show that
has a premise that can go on for as long
as it needs to
but also doesn't have to go on that long
at all
i think that could be really fun
that's mike now brian yes if you don't
mind my asking
uh would you please reenact the theme
song from sliders
wasn't it like wasn't it like
was it something like that i don't
remember i honestly don't remember i
remember
the little logo would pop up and go
sliders
that's all i remember that's what i was
looking for i'm gl i hope our audience
is happy to know that this is the video
they can watch if they want to watch tom
slowly die inside as brian and i talk
it's just
i feel like i'm staring into the dark
crystal right now what did you
watch what else did you want us to say
if not true college i don't know
he just wanted us all to say far escape
and then go home that's what he wants i
also said far escape i put my soul
out on a shopping board and then i let
you guys
cut it up into little pieces nina what
was the true calling team though
um it was like somebody said
it was like one of those like
evanescence knockoff it's the small
building the smallville face
that's the smaller theme it was it was
indistinguishable
i like looked up the opening credits and
i was like this sounds like smallville
written by evanescence and i turned it
off tom do you remember
you remember the far skate theme song
because i do yeah
escape things no the fire escape theme
song sounds like your most obnoxious
friend
seeing the rick and morty theme song at
karaoke when they're already like half a
bottle of tequila in it's just this like
way too big i thought could do do you
want to play it bro no because i thought
it was
we can't play i thought it was far
escape
going to far escape right
we're on
i'm gonna go learn an actual trade skill
and uh yeah i'll see you around
okay bye sir
love you guys love you too do you guys
want to watch
your calling or no i don't want to die
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
[Music]
video